home
finally for the holidays
pure joy for these loved ones as they
reunite in the state of queensland and
australia after having been separated
because of the pandemic
welcome hi mr amazus who was missing my
son and daughter-in-law who have been
living in
england for five years and uh
we're planning to get married in 2020 in
greece and we were all going but of
course
we couldn't do that so they they got
married in september this year and we're
now welcoming them home after five years
so we're so excited but not everyone is
so lucky unlike domestic travellers
international travelers into the state
of queensland will still require two
weeks of quarantine diana ward lives in
a bordering state and hasn't been with
her family all year
it's been over eight months since i saw
my family and luckily i can get back for
christmas but my brother is still
overseas and can't get back into
queensland officials say all travel in
the state will get easier once the
vaccination rate goes up to 90 percent
we haven't been on a plane for 18 months
so it's yeah and but
just coming back
it's going to be exciting walking on the
beach
these families won't need screens to
stay connected this holiday season
just time to hug and kiss face to face
leah harding al jazeera